Jake it's so good to see you come give
me a hug I'm not gonna eat you also
don't hug me because I will try to eat
you
this is such a surprise I haven't seen
you since I transferred here how's Amy
she's great we're married and she's a
sergeant now wow yeah how's everything
here yeah same old same old guess who's
here Herman Herman always playing
Yahtzee knew everybody's name worship
Satan did he he never mentioned that
shut up about it it is exhausting well I
I'm Charles I'm Jake's best friend
Charles he's serving three life
sentences no need to flex so Caleb we're
tracking a serial killer and I was
thinking you could help us get inside
his head just because I ate humans
doesn't mean that I'm inhuman Jake Caleb
come on that's not what I meant I'm just
kidding I'm probably friends with the
guy online what's his deal well he's
been murdering young men and cutting out
their hearts ooh what I would never eat
out hard I stick to the normal stuff
butts and thighs one time I ate a foot
but it was nasty yeah I could see that
you know what there was some weird guy
on the Forum recently before him yeah
it's a chat room for people who like to
talk about eating human beings but
definitely won't act on it wink yeah
it's hosted on Reddit obviously anyways
he showed up from out of nowhere asking
questions about cutting out Hearts
really do you know anything else about
him I've never seen him on there before
but you could check the logs I'll
approve you I'm an admin oh you might
want to switch to incognito mode
otherwise your targeted ads will be
pretty cannibal specific ah good to know
well it was good to see you Caleb send
me that info
thank you
Captain lunch good to see you but if
you're here who's guarding Hades it's
deputy chief lunch now unsurprisingly
I've been promoted above you and now I'm
here to evaluate you what happened to
Brent he retired and moved to Charleston
to be closer to his grandchildren so
much for dying at your desk with little
dignity interesting I will attempt to
cooperate with you under these new
circumstances don't sweet talk me halt
I gave it my best shot let's
begin when we first met we had some good
times
[Music]
looks like we both want that stapler
seems that way based on what happened
so when did it all go south 1989
I was up for a big promotion which would
have fast tracked my career launch
offered to write a letter on my behalf
but instead she torpedoed me because of
something that happened the night before
she was to turn it in Madeline
would you care for a drink I'd love one
I'm sure you can tell I'm quite drunk
I've had a couple that build up the
nerve I think we both know what I'm
about to say Raymond
I don't think we need to say anything
I'm gay that's what I was going to tell
you
well then
some of you just met detective pimento
and of course some of you knew him
before he went undercover Hitchcock and
Scully you guys still work here the only
way they're getting rid of us is in a
body bag it actually happened once but
it was a false alarm detector pimento
will be returning to his old desk
Peralta will temporarily be moved to the
break room questions what'd you do
undercover I worked for Jimmy The
Butcher figures that is an A-list
mobster tell me literally everything
everyone shut up pretty much just a Bag
Man for him I mean I did some other
stuff
[Music]
um we usually try to tell funnier little
stories well there's nothing funny about
what I did for the butcher I've had to
learn not to Blink because every time I
close my eyes I see a fresh Horror oh
dark how do you keep your eyes moist no
actually I have a very funny story about
keeping my eyes moist
nope still not getting that Vibe man
really I'll get there that's my bad
everybody
no
yeah you played violin at my wedding
you're believed nose no my name is Jerry
by Friday what
it doesn't matter I need your help can
you please hand me the keys that are
down there
thank you I love Keys oh and this is for
you
as they say in my country
right and what country is that again
Honolulu Okay
you know if it's all the same I'd really
just rather have the key you know one
cheeky I don't want the key perfect
thank you malipnos no it's jetty
but I can't clean that son
that's a little different the first time
ladies and gentlemen widows and widowers
welcome to the all ages piano Lounge
adults only show
I'm Horatio Velveteen dope man it's a
little song I wrote myself
Rosa Rosa Rosa goes like this
blows up Rosa Rosa
Rose is so crowded in here and the
lighting is way too sexy to see anything
right there on the floor
[Music]
he's right in front of you
a little bit to the left
my left my left my left my left
come on this way
he's in a red shirt no not the Asian
dudes
look ribbond yellow crested warbler
agreement a yellow crested warbler no
you're too excited the Warblers are
common bird and then I said which
metamorphosis Kafka or Ovid he loves it
he loves it oh so that's the joke now
you tell it oh okay so a professor walks
into a rare books collection no you've
ruined it no it's not funny look Raymond
a yellow crested warbler look Raymond a
yellow crested word not excited enough
they may be common but they're still
Earth the 92nd Street by had a wonderful
Symposium on just that topic that's it
you're getting it
oh don't say cool instead say indeed oh
indeed indeed indeed indeed indeed
that's weird look Raymond a yellow
crested warbler yes that's the right
level of excitement for such a bird you
capture the essence of Kevin you've done
it correction I've accomplished it
indeed indeed indeed indeed indeed
indeed
it's growing on me
[Music]
grab the dog
look at me
if not blow this for us you know what I
knew this wasn't going to work it never
has we should have just gone out for
dinner to a restaurant like we do every
year why did you make me invite them I
made to invite them because I like them
they're good people
Santiago are you hiding in my bathroom
with a dog that you're definitely
allergic to
occupied
we will once again pick up where we left
off the infinitude gym you guys are
still doing this you know it's April now
yeah Terry we're still doing it and
we're still having a great time why are
the gems so pale I guess scully's inside
stabbed all the color out of them I
don't know babe you're undercutting my
whole thing with Terry here anyways the
infinitude gems will go back to Bill
whose life seems to have unraveled even
further tough March for you there bud
yeah just a heads up I sold my pants
with the pockets so I'll be putting the
gems in my undies this time no I'll give
him a fanny pack can I keep it this
could be just what I need to turn my
life around yeah
I don't have to do anything for it do I
because I will if you ask I'll do
anything even
what's that supposed to represent no one
answer that